the names go on and on more than 20 000
of them shot here during stalin's great
terror in 1937 and 38 sometimes hundreds
in a day
and this the boot of a firing range is
just one of numerous sites across russia
where the victims of stalin's
repressions were executed and thrown
into mass graves often without their
relatives knowing what had happened to
them
now the russian state which tends to
sweep under the carpet the nature and
scale of stalin's crimes is looking to
snuff out the one organization which has
sought to document and catalogue
stalinist repressions and to give its
victims names ironically under foreign
agent legislation essentially calling
them enemies of the state which is
exactly what the tens of thousands of
people here were executed for
memorial's huge archive of four million
names tells their stories in scraps and
mementos and it has always been a battle
to remember those the state would prefer
to forget
and how does it make you feel when you
look at this
so this this carpet is
andreas great aunt sewed this for her
daughter when she was in a forced labor
camp or gulag in the 1930s it's part of
a collection of objects from the gulag
on display at memorial's moscow
headquarters
why do you think the authorities are
going after memorial why do you think
it's a threat to them
because
now
kgb is ruling again
he's ruling the country
actually
russia's prosecutor general has two
entities in its sites the historical
organization memorial international and
its human rights arm
today's ruling shuts down memorial
international but it does not bode well
for the human rights organization either
absolutely
2021 started with the return to russia
and immediate imprisonment of opposition
leader alexei navalny after he was
poisoned with novichok
it ends with the shuttering of the
country's most important human rights
organization
campaign has promised to fight on but
this year more than any in his 21 year
rule has shown how vladimir putin is
reverting to type with a soviet style
crushing of dissent
diana mcnay sky news moscow ready